I can either present feelings so this is
a whirlwind just how do we solve that
all right so that's called a depressed
cubic it's not no quadratic term I've
got to rewrite it in this form but the
constant on the right hand side because
that's what the 16th century Italians
did because they couldn't write
something like that because I didn't
acknowledge negative numbers so if they
had it like that then that would mean
that that would need to be a negative
number and they didn't like negative
numbers quite ironic considering night
but maybe the mind subtraction oh yeah
yeah so they wouldn't have done this one
yeah but this is my example one yeah
okay so there's no reason to present it
in this form other than that it ties in
with history and I'm using Y for the
depressed cubic an X for the general
cubic so that we can sort of keep track
of what equation we're doing so rather
than go through and solve this
numerically because it's a lot more
complicated we're going to solve it
algebraically all right but the details
will be a bit later there's the solution
we'll see how we got there but that's
the solution so if that's your depressed
cubic equation then that is your
solution so it involves cube roots
nested square roots is the discriminant
symbol is is that and the B and I come
from your equation okay so there are
similarities there with quadratics this
is a discriminant it does distinguish
like how many real roots the cubic
equation will have every cubic equation
will have one real root guarantee and
then the other two will either be real
or complex
alright so to apply that here we're
doing that form that equation expanding
this out
there's our values for a and B just note
that 1/2 B is negative 1 because we want
half B here is their expanding fur Delta
we get negative 98 over 27 told you I
made it so it would have nice numbers
and there is what the solution tells us
okay I'm just gonna press the next
button without comment ok how many real
solutions did this particular cubic have
3 for 3 yeah that one like that is cos
d3 real solutions what's this doing me
if you're an experienced for unit mass
teacher then you would probably
recognize the solution to this problem
reasonably quickly I'm not an
experienced for you the maths teachers
I've worked it out in considerable
detail so three real solutions an
expression involving complex numbers
what's going on
well it simplifies to this you know two
five five significant figures so one
plus that I plus one minus that I gives
us two okay so these solution should say
a solution is y equals two we saw
that this has three real solutions this
is giving us one of them so you can find
the others by factorizing in that sort
of thing yeah polynomial division or
this involves taking cube roots who says
the cube root of that is that right this
has three cube roots doesn't hmm so
we've taken the you know the principal
cube root or the most obvious cube root
or whatever but there are other cube
roots and I believe but don't what it
means that if you take you know various
complex cube roots of those and combine
them in different ways to get the three
solutions that make sense that okay so
back to our original main axis general
cubic we made that substitution and
arrived at that depressed cubic we
solved that and found it had y equals
two so now we reverse substitute x
equals y plus two so it's two plus two
equals four and so it's just shifting it
back isn't yeah so this has x equals
four as a solution
there it is I believe that this method
always gives us the right most real
solution I don't know if that's actually
true it wouldn't surprise me perhaps if
the leading term was negative then it
would give you the left-most for
instance but I haven't spent much time
thinking about it so here's a quick
summary so far to solve the general
cubic you can make this substitution and
then well sorry it's not so much make
this substitution that's the machinery
behind this right so to solve it X does
equal this where thing being banged out
and to work that hope you're going
reverse trying you have to work those
out because you've got you a B and C and
you can work out your Delta Lucy buggy
capital A and capital B then you can
work out your white as you've got your
buddy in your Delta then you can work
out your X as demonstrated here well
soon so this comes from the substitution
that we made this comes from solving the
depressed cubic which we're going to
look at in detail and just to comment
here we're doing this part algebraically
the part we just did with the
substitution of course you can do the
substitution of x equals y minus of a
and do all the expanding and simplifying
in terms of a B and C grow quite hairy
but not difficult it's just algebra so
I'm not doing that in the presentation
it's in the article quick example to
solve this one right if we work out our
a ml b then we work out our discriminant
then we work out our Y then we work out
our X since I wrote a computer program
to do all this
because that's what helped me to find a
second equation with nicer solutions